[Música]
una nueva caravana de migrantes partió
desde el sur de México miles de personas
buscan permisos temporales para circular
por el suelo de ese país y luego ir a
Estados Unidos este intento ocurre días
después de que encontraran a más de 53
personas muertas en un camión en Texas
el incendio en Machu Picchu ya está
controlado en un 90 por ciento según las
autoridades de Perú las llamas No
afectaron a la ciudad inca que fue
declarada por la UNESCO como patrimonio
de la humanidad en esta emisión les
contaremos Cuál es la situación actual
del fuego
Canadá también sufre las consecuencias
por la revocación del caso Row versus
weight que permitía el aborto en Estados
Unidos el país invirtió más de 3,5
millones de dólares para que las
clínicas fronterizas garanticen el
derecho a las estadounidenses
Bienvenidos a las noticias dedicadas al
continente americano yo soy María Clara
calle y es un placer saludarlos
comenzamos en México desde el sur del
país salió una nueva caravana de
migrantes primero quieren ir a la ciudad
de Huixtla a solicitar permisos para
circular por México durante 30 días y
luego Buscar la frontera con Estados
Unidos la mayoría de los migrantes son
de Venezuela y Cuba uno de sus temores
es terminar muertos en un tráiler como
le pasó a 53 migrantes en el estado de
Texas Rafael Pérez trae la historia
migrante marcada por la tragedia de
Texas en el trayecto son visibles los
estigmas de la inseguridad y el temor de
experimentar un destino similar ante la
53 personas que murieron en un tráiler
La semana pasada miles de personas
partieron esta madrugada desde la
frontera sur de México en condición de
migrantes mucho dolor estamos en luto
por eso realmente hasta el momento no sé
si se registraron muerte de con
Patriotas venezolanos pero igual nos
duele fueron migrantes hasta mexicano si
no me equivoco hubieron en esa muerte y
realmente nos duela todo hermano a pesar
del miedo dejan todo atrás e intentan
Buscar un futuro mejor el ejército
mexicano ha desplegado al menos 30.000
efectivos militares en ambas fronteras
en tareas migratorias provocando que la
muchedumbre tome rutas alternativas e
inseguras ve allá ya la consecuencia que
pasó con con los otros compañeros
migrantes por [__] rutas que no no son
favorables ni aconsejables traen
consecuencias que
bueno ya vieron la experiencia con los
Hermanos migrantes perder la vida los
integrantes de esta nueva caravana van
camino Huixtla donde solicitarán
permisos temporales para circular por
todo el país Normalmente se suben a
cualquier vehículo que les pueda aliviar
el paso el recuerdo de Texas hace
cambiar la opinión de algunos no
miedo a un accidente miedo que nos
agarre migración el miedo más grande yo
le tengo en México
esta multitud conformada por niños
adultos y jóvenes cuenta como la décima
caravana en lo que va de año y la
tercera más numerosa registrada en este
periodo
en noticias de Estados Unidos los
legisladores del estado de Nueva York
aprobaron nuevas leyes que restringen el
porte de armas y así disminuyen el
impacto de la sentencia de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia los legisladores
estatales dieron una lista de lugares
públicos en los que se prohíbe el
armamento como Time Square y también
obligan a que quienes quieran una
licencia deporte de armas tengan más
capacitaciones la decisión llega después
de que la Corte Suprema anulará las
restrictivas leyes de Nueva York y por
primera vez dijera que las personas
podían portar armas en lugares públicos
para defenderse ahora la normativa
neoyorquina entrará en vigor el primero
de septiembre luego de que la
gobernadora demócrata Katy la promulca
la revocación de Rover versus White en
Estados Unidos también tiene efectos en
Canadá en las clínicas de las provincias
fronterizas se están preparando para
recibir pacientes estadounidenses lo que
obliga al Primer Ministro Justin trudo a
renoir una promesa de campaña que no ha
cumplido mejorar el acceso a las
clínicas de aborto les contamos más en
este reporte
Hola Sara soy Caroline solo quería que
supieras que hemos tenido la primera
mujer de Estados Unidos que solicita un
aborto viene de Ohio los preparativos
están en marcha en esta clínica de
aborto de Toronto para algo que nunca
pensaron que sucedería tratar a una
paciente estadounidense muchas de las
personas con las que hemos hablado en
Estados Unidos sienten probablemente que
la primera opción sería tratar de ir a
otro estado haremos todo lo posible para
acomodar a las mujeres que vienen de
Estados Unidos los defensores del
derecho a decidir dicen que Estados
Unidos acaba de retroceder 50 años algo
que no quieren que suceda en Canadá
monstruos
la mayoría de nosotros Nunca pensamos
hace 10 años que Rose versus wade sería
derogada y ahora tenemos que re examinar
nuestros pensamientos y cómo es la
atención del aborto en Canadá entonces
creo que eso nos dio una pequeña llamada
de atención en Canadá tras la anulación
de Rose versus wade canada invirtió 3,5
millones de dólares para mejorar el
acceso al aborto en el país en algunos
casos las mujeres todavía tienen que
viajar a través de Canadá para obtener
atención especializada
el derecho a elegir es un derecho de la
mujer y solo suyo nunca retrocederemos
en proteger y promover el acceso al
aborto seguro en Canadá y en todo el
mundo y no podemos dar por sentado
ningún derecho incluido este fundamental
la inversión está destinada a
tranquilizar a las mujeres incluso a
pesar de la envalentonada oposición anti
aborto Brian jenkins está entre ellos
protesta todas las mañanas frente a esta
clínica de abortos en Montreal
la noticia de Estados Unidos fue bien
recibida estábamos felices yo estaba
feliz Es un gran paso la vida es
importante debe vencer a la muerte
el partido conservador en Canadá dice
que no quiere reabrir el debate sobre el
aborto pero una docena de miembros de
sus funcionarios electos están
abiertamente en contra de esta práctica
Después de varios días del incendio
forestal en Machu Picchu los bomberos
lograron controlar las llamas en un 90%.
sin embargo las autoridades no descartan
que el fuego vuelva a surgir por Los
Fuertes vientos cerca de la antigua
ciudad en lo alto de las montañas de
Perú previamente conversamos con José
José bastante jefe del parque
arqueológico Nacional de Machu Picchu él
nos explicó si hubo daños o no en la
ciudad inca para empezar hay que
entender que lo que está inscrito en la
lista de patrimonio
Mundial de la UNESCO es el santuario
histórico parque arqueológico nacional
que ocupa una superficie de más de
37.000 hectáreas Dentro de este espacio
tenemos más de 60 monumentos
arqueológicos y más de 300 kilómetros de
caminos prehispánicos
el lugar donde se inició el incendio el
día 28 alrededor de las 12 del mediodía
es en la parte posterior del monumento
arqueológico llama cancha que está a
kilómetros en línea recta de la llacta O
ciudad inca o lo que erróneamente
algunas veces llamamos ciudadela José
bastante también nos precisó Cuál es la
situación del incendio forestal en Machu
Picchu bueno básicamente es un 30% de el
área natural
que ha sido afectada en el caso del
monumento arqueológico llama cancha
la afectación es mínima porque se hacen
labores permanentes de corte de
vegetación y de mantenimiento
actualmente está controlado al 99%
todavía quedan unos pocos en la parte
superior
que son espacios inaccesibles para los
brigadistas y bomberos forestales pero
estamos monitoreando de una manera
permanente
las cifras de pobreza en América Latina
incrementaron con la pandemia y Brasil
ha sido uno de los países más afectados
casi 10 millones de personas pasaron a
vivir en condición de pobreza entre el
2019 y el 2021 en Sao Paulo un sacerdote
atienda en su iglesia a las personas que
van todos los días para buscar comida su
labor ha sido aplaudida pero también hay
quienes lo critican por su postura
política el informe es de Samuel Salgado
él es Julio lancelotti sacerdote de la
iglesia San Miguel Arcángel en Sao Paulo
Brasil durante toda su trayectoria ha
tratado de ayudar a las personas más
vulnerables económicamente
convirtiéndose en una figura antisistema
la exclusión de las personas es un
efecto del sistema capitalista
neoliberal Así que será difícil cambiar
el efecto sin cambiar la causa
según la red brasileña de investigación
sobre soberanía y seguridad alimentaria
más de la mitad de la población es decir
125 millones de personas no tienen
certeza si contarán con un plato de
comida al terminar el día es el caso de
Kawa Víctor Este joven habitante de
calle es un asiduo de la iglesia del
padre
si no tuviéramos al cura Bueno
estaríamos en la misma situación en la
que estábamos es un ángel
pero la labor del cura Rebelde como le
conocen No es aplaudida por todos en
Brasil y más aún después de mostrar su
afinidad con el ex mandatario y
candidato presidencial Lula da Silva
lancelotti se ha enfrentado a las
autoridades en varias ocasiones
la situación empeoró empeoró con el
aumento de la pobreza la miseria el
desempleo y también el recrudecimiento
de la pandemia son 14 millones más de
brasileños los que pasan hambre
Comparado con 2020 una problemática a
tener en cuenta de Cara a las próximas
elecciones presidenciales del mes de
octubre
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
frases 24
[Música]